back in Washington talks appear to be
stalled on a deal to raise the debt
ceiling and avoid major Financial
Fallout for the country economists warn
if there is no agreement by the end of
the month 401ks could plunge and the
economy could tip into a deep recession
Scott McFarland is on Capitol Hill Scott
good morning
Vlad good morning to you one week in one
day until this June 1st deadline the
treasury Department's ex day the date in
which the economy could suffer an
immediate shock but now some House
Republicans are questioning that
deadline itself House Majority Leader
Steve scalise said yesterday we'd like
to see more transparency on how they
came up with that date and came to that
date which opens up concern that if GOP
members don't even agree on the deadline
both sides still remain far apart but
the bottom line Remains the Same
Republicans want the president to cut
spending and Democrats will spend part
of this day criticizing Republicans for
trying to cut access to nutritional
benefits nutritional assistance and
other social programs
and last night ended with a dizzying mix
of optimism and pessimism
Senate Republican leader Mitch McConnell
told an audience yesterday people should
quote relax in that America won't
default but time is tight house leaders
want to put the bill in front of their
members for three days before any vote
and then there's Memorial Day and the
house Speaker said last night he's
uncertain if he'll keep the house in
session until a deal is done Tony
all right Scott thank you very much